look read the Bible every single man had
multiple wives not single woman had
multiple husbands it's against the will
of God it's disgusting in the eyes are
right there I think his biblical
exegesis is a little bit weak here the
point he's making though that it's it's
different for a man than it is for a
woman that's absolutely true and why is
it different because of the possibility
of pregnancy absolutely true what he
says about uh you know people in the
Bible having multiple wives in the Old
Testament
that is true
God doesn't approve of that in fact when
the men take multiple wives things go
really really bad you see this
throughout the Book of Genesis
when the men fail to trust in God's plan
and start to try to take matters into
their own hands let's say for instance
man can't have a child
starts to you know sleep with the the
wife's handmaiden or whatever things
start to go really really bad and it
leads to Millennia along problems for
Humanity so he's observing yes men do
have these multiple wives in the Old
Testament what he doesn't point out is
that is that is not the will of God